today is the most significant day in the
history of the NCAA the last day on
planet Earth in the United States of
America in college athletics where name
image and likeness laws will not be on
the books and kids will be not allowed
to make money off of their name image
and like list
today is the last day that amateurism
has at least a shadow meaning in our
culture a major ruling from the Supreme
Court involving the most seismic change
in college sports happened in 2021 and
its aftershocks are still ricocheting
across the landscape non-pro athletes
getting paid for use of their name image
and likeness until last year banned by
the NCAA is now allowed and it's
changing the face of sports and business
radically according to open endorse
Brands spent almost a billion dollars in
the first year of the new rules and that
number is only going to grow
but some of the biggest winners they may
surprise you top female athletes are
cashing in and women's basketball
players are standing Center Stage
your heels you want your heels to go
down
he took a pre-ride poop nio it really is
pretty surreal I don't think I've really
wrapped my head around the concept that
I am making money just doing the thing
that I love
starting her sophomore year AZ fuds
already signed deals with Chipotle
American Eagle and others earning tens
of thousands of dollars leveraging her
on-court prowess and off-court social
media following she's also getting
massive investment from the pro game as
well becoming one of the first athletes
to sign with Steph Curry's sc30 ink the
two even designed to shoot together when
Steph Curry would wear during his 2021
NBA Finals MVP performance
it's an investment directly into a
future player but also the future of
women's basketball and especially for
the women's game nil deals may not only
benefit the students but the pro game as
well
[Music]
I'm gonna call Carly knows everything
hey hi Carly I have my TV mounted on the
wall of my room and I'm wondering if I'm
moving back into the same room can I
just take the TV off and leave them out
kind of all the little things that I
said I have too much of
um AC fud can almost trick you into
thinking she's just a regular college
student you can't judge me by what you
see here today
foreign
we just finished our summer session so
I'm about to move out I've got to
completely move out to re-move into the
exact same apartment
it's starting to stress me out I gotta
carry this back
[Music]
who's gonna help you move all the big
stuff out oh well you see I leave
tomorrow so I will be probably playing
an all-nighter but not if my mom is
watching this I will be going to sleep
early and getting my rest
[Music]
don't let a messy dorm room and
procrastination fool you though it's
very clear very quick that there is
nothing ordinary about her
Bud was the class of 2021's number one
consensus recruit while she was playing
for St John's College High School out of
DC now she's playing for one of the most
storied and winning programs in any
sport in history
the University of Connecticut Huskies
the national championship goes to
connect
[Music]
[Applause]
winners of 11 national championships
producers of Olympians and multiple WNBA
MVPs
but AZ has something that the
trailblazing women of UConn's past never
had the opportunity to not only play
basketball but get paid for it I
remember just learning that you could
profit off of your name and brand and
like I could profit off of AZ the
basketball player not just AZ the person
which I didn't really understand why you
couldn't because at least for me like AC
the basketball player is also easy the
person like basketball is such a huge
role in my life that I didn't understand
why I wouldn't be able to profit from it
it's important to understand exactly
what made this all possible in 2021
after Decades of debate lawsuits and
legislation the NCAA prompted by a
unanimous ruling by the Supreme Court
finally relented on one of its longest
standing strictures that athletes could
not in any way be compensated Beyond
scholarships and small stipends from
their schools
it would only take a few months before
AZ a freshman at the time would sign her
first major deal with Chipotle before
the freshmen even got to play a game for
the Huskies she Inked her first nil deal
as a college athlete Ambassador for the
Magnificent Mexican restaurant chain you
were on the
on the Leading Edge of something that
feels
for those of us who've been looking at
sports for a long time like a very
meaningful moment in in sports like the
economics are changing the role of
sports in society is changing
we see that from the outside you're
inside it does it feel momentous to you
you can tell like how important it is
but at the same time like this is all I
know in college basketball is nil so
like I'm still trying to find my way in
it by my groove and stuff but like I
know how important it is and
um kind of like the people before me
paved the way and set that path for me
to be able to do this and how important
it is for me to be able to take
advantage of this and be able to
continue this on for the athletes to
come
while colleges and universities still
can't directly compensate their athletes
those athletes can legally be paid by
Third parties who want to use their name
image and likeness or nil
AZ advised closely by a team led by her
parents and her agents has created a
portfolio anchored by relationships with
Chipotle American Eagle sports drink
biosteel and sc30 Brands she already
admired as a successful athlete and
American Teenager I've been lucky that
the deals that I've been approached with
have been things that have been like
really good and things I've liked like
American Eagle is one of my favorite
Brands I always wear their jeans so I
was like one of the easiest like
transitions type things
bioseal was something that I hadn't
really tried before and once I did I
really liked it
on the basketball side it's impossible
to be on UConn's campus and not feel the
weight of History especially when you
see where the team works out
officially called the worth family Yukon
basketball champion center it's a 78 200
square foot complex that costs 40
million dollars
its most striking feature it's split
right down the middle between men's and
women's basketball seemingly identical
when you walk in except while the men's
Team boasts Four national championships
the women's side has more than double
that
and that actually understates their
dominance the team has gone undefeated
in six seasons and its players have been
Staples on the US Olympic team
Hubert and Diana Taurasi are only the
latest in the line of superstars that
began in the early 1990s with Rebecca
Lobo
the Huskies have featured 12 AP national
players of the year including Lobo Maya
Moore twice Brianna Stewart three times
and most recently Paige Beckers we'll
get to her in a minute
banners are I mean they're overwhelming
for me but you know and I'm not you know
sitting in there standing in in your
shoes what do you take from that
personally I think it can be seen for
sure as like overwhelming kind of
pressure to live up to those standards
but I use it kind of as motivation this
is our Yukon program like there's no
need to compare ourselves to the Past
like we're not those players that we see
on the wall we're different players like
I'm easy I'm not Sue bird we need to
forge our own path in our own story in
the Yukon books
those former UConn Stars helped to
establish the Yukon team as a product to
watch over the last decade meteorites
moved from Connecticut public television
to SNY and now include Fox Sports with
game coverage mixed with behind the
scenes documentaries UConn has become
one of the biggest platforms for women's
basketball
the Yukon women's team is so well known
that at the moment it's arguably a
better platform than most if not all of
the professional women's teams or even
the WNBA overall
well I don't think there's any greater
female sports Collegiate brand than
UConn women's basketball it's on TV you
can follow those athletes in a way that
if you compare it to the WNBA you don't
always get consistency of coverage local
or International markets you're not
always able to follow those athletes it
feels so nice to be back this is Angela
ruggiro she's a former hockey player and
four-time Olympian
she now runs Sports Innovation lab
that's a boston-based company that uses
data science to help teams and leagues
understand their fans and figure out how
to better engage them the future of
sports really is how do you optimize and
drive Revenue in these digital spaces
these digital communities so Collegiate
athletes I think are going to really
benefit from the change in the nil
ecosystem because they're authentically
themselves they're using these platforms
already and they're being entertainers
not sure how to work this
I think it's recording fans of women's
sports and female athletes want more
authenticity these fans are dying for
not just the game and the stats and the
scores they want to know what you're
doing 24 7. they want to know what these
female athletes think what are they
wearing who are they dating what do they
care about what are their causes and
that's going to build a wave of support
when those athletes graduate that
they'll hopefully bring to those WNBA
teams I think that this is really an
incredible opportunity for me and all of
women's basketball to be able to benefit
and it's sad knowing that this is kind
of our most profitable age
so I think that that's also a big an
important part of being able to use nil
now before going pro
love yourself
but Dance videos and homemade Tostino's
ads can only take that mission so far
knows that success on the court comes
first and will allow everything else to
follow
and while UConn has had a storied
history their last championship was way
back in 2016.
lucky for her she's playing with not
only just a good friend and dance
partner but the best college player in
the country Paige Beckers
Paige buckets Beckers is also one of the
biggest college students when it comes
to nil deals striking the first NCAA
athlete deal with Gatorade as well as
Partnerships with stockx and cash app
and she has been estimated to
potentially bring in a million dollars
in nil deals
too much but this is for some horse
riding
yes
this is my first one involving a live
animal during the last week of official
summer workouts AZ page and their
teammates finished their last session
and went over to UConn's horse barn for
some team bonding
I have an extra large right so when
you're working with the horses you want
to try to stay calm and relaxed you're
gonna make him anxious I'm sorry typical
day and stores Connecticut
that's what we do and we don't play
basketball
peasants
farewell
it was a light moment before everyone
went off to hang with their families and
get rested up for the season
a few weeks later Beckers would announce
that her 22-23 season was over before it
even started UConn women's basketball
Junior guard Paige Beckers suffered a
torn ACL in her left knee and will miss
the 2022-23 season it's an injury AZ
knows all too well having gone through
her own ACL tear in 2019 while Paige's
absence will test the team's depth and
medal what was on display in stores and
apparent in conversations with Az was
that she and Beckers were intent on
using their increasingly higher profiles
not just to benefit themselves but their
entire team
bruh pains no you didn't
sweet
oh I'm so excited an AC's case that
means free Chipotle thank you
both AC and Paige are conscious of the
inequality that still exists in nil
while all the players in this room share
the benefit of playing at UConn not all
can or will get the deal's Asian page
have already signed sophomores the first
since I catered people outside of your
world of actually doing it speculate
about the consequences and maybe some of
the unintended consequences of NFL you
think well
know the really prominent players like
you are going to benefit and then other
players are not and so maybe there's
some you know jealousy or Envy or
whatever how do you make sure that it
doesn't we were very tight we're a super
close group I mean you've been to stores
or not there's not much else to do
besides play basketball and hang out
with each other and I think it also is
because that whatever deals we get like
we share with each other so I have a
deal with Chipotle and my whole team
whenever they watch fully they let me
know or American Eagle they can get
whatever they want they just let me know
and I think it goes both ways with
whatever deals other people have that
we're super open and always willing to
share I think I'm posting on Instagram
about this this would be the last team
meal for AZ before going on summer break
and when we next caught up with her it
would be about as far from a dorm room
in stores that you could possibly get
AC's out in La this week to do a
commercial shoot for a new Under Armor
shoe alongside both Steph and Seth Curry
along with her is her family including
her former coaches and current business
screens her mom and dad we make sure
that that one of us is at everything
that she does just just to give her that
support so I've been at a lot of them
still blows my mind like okay wow you
look really cute in that outfit but it
just doesn't like really
I don't know sink in that that she's
this public figure for lack of a better
word
the partnership with curry is both
historic and important well beyond the
deal itself AZ was the first woman and
the first college athlete to join the
sc30 brand and has developed a
friendship with curry
she fully concedes to initially being a
bit Starstruck
I mean I try to keep my cool
him and
enough on set but in my head I'm going a
little bit crazy yeah
I first met him at Curry Camp right
after my freshman year of high school I
got invited I was one of the first two
girls invited to camp and then I was
invited the next year as well and then
Prairie brand reached out to my agent at
my group and they let me know and I was
all for it
and working out with someone that I look
up to and someone that inspires me so
getting to see firsthand like him in
action like what he does behind the
scenes
like I get to challenge myself and
compete a little bit with him it's
amazing
shooting ads for unreleased apparel
isn't something cameras are welcome into
but AZ is also in La for basketball
getting private workouts with Steph
Curry's own trainer Carl Bergstrom az's
also been a part of Curry camps
including this past summer in San
Francisco she also helped design a shoe
for the sc30 line that Curry himself
wore in an NBA Finals game this past
season the 2022 Bill Russell NBA Finals
MVP award goes to Stephen Curry
did you know that on average women have
30 percent less income for retirement
CIA was one of like the first Brands
where I kind of got to use my platform
to speak out about Title IX and
retirement equality I think that's
definitely something that I still want
to continue to do but that was uh big
for me because I'm still trying to
figure out what I stand for and what I
support and things I want to be able to
support
he's gotta formulate her own
understanding and opinion about life we
all have our own perspectives and that's
what makes us all unique we all have our
own opinions and experiences and I'm
just proud that she found the level of
comfort to be able to speak on something
that she had no idea existed I didn't
know it existed retirement inequality
women were tied with 30 30 less income
in retirement than men I didn't know
that was a thing and I think from being
a girl Dad having her come along has
awakened my senses to things that my
wife has experienced as a player that
I've seen firsthand being being a girls
basketball coach that the girls endure
it's been it's been pretty pretty
tremendous honestly
and as a fellow girl dad Curry's
involvement with an equality campaign
was notable but not surprising for AZ
who said she was drawn to his brand as
much for his off the court Persona as
his championship pedigree
he is a very big family man you can see
that like with his kids with his wife
um and I'm huge with my family like I do
everything with them they're with me
here on this trip so I think the family
aspect was huge and just kind of his
personality like he welcomed me in right
away even when I was at Camp he made me
feel part of that group and special just
being here like I feel like I'm really
part of this part of this brand part of
this team part of the curry family and I
couldn't be more grateful Kobe Bryant
forever of course remembered as an NBA
legend and rightfully so but as a father
of four daughters crazy also filled a
void that AZ and others thought might be
left empty after Kobe Bryant and his
daughter Gigi died tragically in a
helicopter crash in 2020. Brian had been
arguably the biggest advocate in the
world for the women's game and without
him it was unclear who would carry that
torch that was kind of a big question
when Kobe died was like who was gonna
step up and continue to like help fight
for women's basketball and help kind of
raise the game and I think Steph
um is doing a really good job of like
trying like inviting women to um his
camp and little things like that that
are helping to elevate the women's game
and like this deal is incredible being
not just the first like nil the own
College athlete but also the first
female signed to his brand I don't even
really know what word to use to describe
that feeling when I first signed it and
being here now like it means so much
az's connection to and Reliance on her
own family was on full display in La
she'd come to the West Coast with her
mom dad and two younger brothers and her
success as a burgeoning business
provides some fun perks on ships like
this I love just watching my parents
reaction because they've been in the
game they've always played um in college
and they played professionally so seeing
their reaction to kind of where I am
it's just really funny I mean like my
dad loves being around all these NBA
players my mom loves seeing all these
high-level workouts and so I was seeing
like them happy it's it's really fun
AC's parents both played division one
basketball in college and coached her
throughout her youth which she credits
made her the way she is
even if sometimes it's not so easy to
grow up with two coaches for parents
part of the reason that I am the way I
am is because well they didn't really
compliment much so I always had
something to work on I was always
working hard I think they did a very
good job obviously
played really bad I would hear about
that but they did a really good job of
separating mom and dad from coach yeah
like I remember when I was younger my
dad would take me out to get ice cream
and stuff after games that was something
when we started coaching that we were
very cognizant of not having that coach
role carryover I Harbor things a little
more so sometimes they'd go get ice
cream and I'd be like yo she sucked why
are you getting ice cream ice cream but
then he really likes ice cream too so
just started the coach I definitely did
not want to have that contentious
relationship at all and so the ice cream
thing became a reminder to me a treat to
like now I get to go back and be dead
[Music]
played at NC State and then Georgetown
in the late 1990s as women's basketball
was starting to gain a bit of traction
and the WNBA was in its formative years
she had to deal with inequalities that
she never wanted her daughter to face
when it came time for AZ to pick a
school her mom had a big influence when
Daisy was getting recruited I felt very
strongly about what is the culture when
I was at Georgetown it was kind of it's
a men's basketball program and not
really much else it's evolved since then
but in our practice time was limited on
the court based on when the men
practiced or you know it's just it was
just all based around the men there's a
lot of schools that she was looking at
where they they had some storied men's
programs but how did the players
interact how does you know what's the
culture on the campus like let's make
sure that we're doing the right thing by
by both the men's and women's program
az's parents were able to go from being
her coaches to fans in the stands but
now have evolved into her Advisory board
on her branding deals I think we spent
the better part of the pandemic
um on seminars and YouTube and listening
talk I probably have a four-year degree
in another cell phone nil just because
it just making sure we understood it as
well as we could to help her but also um
connecting with the right people and
we've been very very fortunate I think
the fact that we have such a great
relationship with her she trusts us
implicitly like we're not going to put
her in a situation that one she doesn't
support the company or doesn't you know
she wants authentic stuff and then we're
not going to put her in a situation that
just isn't isn't good for her yeah I
would definitely say that this past year
my freshman year it was a little
difficult managing I mean I was really
lucky to have my parents so involved so
they did a lot of the background stuff
with my agent so that I wouldn't need to
be on calls and stuff I could focus on
school and basketball but I was still
trying to figure my way out navigate my
first year of college while also
navigating nil stuff so it did feel a
little overwhelming at times but I think
we did a really good job managing now
like looking back on that whole year I
feel a lot more comfortable
as the new season starts az's nil deals
existing and new will be in the
background
expectations are always high at Uconn
and even more attention will be on her
given Becker's injury
while new nil opportunities grab
headlines and attention easy has a clear
focus on what's ahead
how do you raise your nil game how do
you grow it in a way that's
authentically easy I think now that I
have my first year kind of under my belt
I have established my brands with all
these other people but I think like I
need to be able to
kind of like establish my own brand more
like the AZ brand and like post about
myself more as well but I think just
knowing that what your priorities are
that my priorities right now are
basketball and school because without
good grades we'll be able to play and
without basketball I wouldn't have these
opportunities in these deals
[Music]
[Music]